[Música]
un día me desperté y tenía muchos
mensajes en el whatsapp me dicen te
saliste muy bien el cierre madre y yo
cuando porque salir en tierra madre pues
no es tan común no vamos a bodas y me
dicen mira y me desperté con esa foto
con esa foto que me impactó para empezar
y me dije híjole sofía ya no puedes
disimular ya no puedes engañarte la ropa
no se ha encogido
tenía 15 años en esa portada de sierra
madre 15 años
en prepa del colegio americano 15 años
en el teatro hamlet hace mucho hace
muchísimo y sí me impactó esta está
reportaje que sacaron ahora en este
momento en mi vida porque me parece que
siempre siempre hay que aprovechar para
recapacitar
donde estoy muy bien si sé dónde estoy
pero donde estuve y cuál es el camino
que tuve que llegar que tomar para
llegar hasta donde estoy y eso no
siempre es tan fácil ni tan claro y yo
les puedo asegurar que en 1980
no lo tenían nada claro
nací en 1965 en monterrey en esta ciudad
que ahora tiene librerías tiene arte
tiene parques con árboles que no cortan
cada invierno tiene bueno esta ciudad
que ya aprendió también a apreciar sus
montañas en ese entonces la idea del
regio era de trabajar de ser productivo
de la belleza es lo secundario y creo
que tenía su motivo de ser en 1980 esta
ciudad por fin creo que empezaba a
encontrar un equilibrio y qué sucede con
las ciudades que no han encontrado un
equilibrio en las ciudades que apenas
están sobreviviendo están encontrando su
vocación su lugar en el mundo
no buscan arte
tienen que sobrevivir al día siguiente
las crisis del gobierno etcétera que
sucedió con florencia con roma con todas
las ciudades grandes ciudades del mundo
y bueno todavía nos faltan nosotros no
crean que yo ya me doy por por hecha
pero pero qué sucede que primero
tuvieron que sobrevivir antes detenerse
un miguelángel o de empezar a combinar
los colores o de hacer la literatura
etcétera no y monterrey siento que a la
gente de mi generación nos tocó
precisamente este momento en el que ya
se sentía somos regios somos de esta
ciudad industrial pero todavía no
teníamos asegurado el semestre que viene
en realidad entonces muy pocas librerías
muy pocas
oportunidad oportunidades de arte y
resulta que en este momento
en este colegio este si ofrecía
muchísimas oportunidades
me refiero muchísimas en comparación con
otras escuelas de esta ciudad teníamos
nuestra biblioteca bastante buena
biblioteca y teníamos la oferta esta de
descubrir el teatro y yo sabía que como
yo era regia que yo era una niña bien
una niña que no iba a salir en
telenovelas que no no se puede ser
artista porque se ve medio medio mal
pues yo sabía que esto era algo temporal
pero lo disfruté muchísimo y descubrir
muchas cosas dentro de mí pero era
temporal porque porque para esta edad a
los 15 años esta niña ya tenía una idea
de lo que se suponía que debería de ser
ya la historia se le habían contado de
mil maneras en la ciudad en la escuela
en la familia
todo todo tipo de información te va
contando tu historia y entonces mi
historia era bueno un día algún día vas
a hacer algo tal vez pero este nada
tenía que ver con arte y fíjense que qué
triste porque de cierto modo esta niña
ya sabía que le gustaba ser escritora
eso sí sabía lo que sucedía es que pues
me gusta mucho escribir pero tengo que
ser productiva y este y los novelistas
siempre están en otra parte siempre no
sé dónde se criaron pero no se criaron
aquí en monterrey entonces así como se
me había contado la historia yo ni
siquiera me imaginaba que a pesar de que
me gustaba escribir que siempre que nos
decían hoy toca que escriban un cuento
yo era la persona más feliz de este
universo no se me ocurría que entonces
yo debía explorar ese camino para mí ser
novelista o ser cuentista éste era
siempre como si los escritores vivieran
en otro plano de existencia y no
tuvieran hambre y no tuvieran frío y no
tuvieran necesidad de nada más que
describirlo
quizá lo que yo imaginaba pero resulta
que esta niña entonces ya se le había
contado una historia se le había creído
un poco se le había creído de todas
maneras fíjense ahí donde me ven todavía
sin ni idea
en la clase de matemáticas yo leía en la
clase de química y yo leía otra cosa que
no fuera la química y la matemática era
trampa cuando me pescaban pues me
quitaban el libro lo que fuera no pero
este esta niña ya tenía mucho interés
por leer los periódicos porque el
entorno familiar también así me contó mi
historia tienes que conectarte con la
vida y entonces esa lectura de los
periódicos de conectarme con la política
porque la política también es otro
elemento que nos cuenta nuestra vida
este
hizo su labor de cierto modo no vivió
entre crinolinas así este en esta obra
de teatro que por cierto era de folk the
house of fraser de y yo era el menor de
édgar and pop no sé si la conocen este y
resulta que está esta niña algo así
hacia sus cosas y ahorita
que veo esa sonrisa y que veo esa carita
que esa actitud no si veo a alguien que
es muy receptiva a cómo se le contó su
historia pero también recuerdo que no se
lo puedo reclamar tanto porque tenía
este otro aspecto este otro aspecto de
decir este me interesa la vida no me
desconecto de la vida y ley y ley y ley
y este y cuando termina la prepa en el
colegio americano me decidí por una
carrera y como yo tenía que ser muy
productiva pero me gustaba escribir eso
si sabía yo soy escritora pero no es lo
mismo ser escritora que ser novelista
yo soy escritora entonces qué carrera me
ofrecerá la oportunidad de escribir pues
comunicación y me fui a estudiar
comunicación y en la comunicación seguí
muy conectada con la política y todo
pero pero siempre siempre creyendo esto
el futuro es de los jóvenes
entonces mientras tanto estás esperando
vives entre paréntesis esperando el
futuro esperando el futuro cuando será
el futuro y si participe en proyectos de
política escribir guiones de teatro
también escribir fíjense en la escuela
ya de aquí a escribir guiones de teatro
a pararme en escenarios otra vez ya en
otro plan también como actriz como
cantante un poquito luego este viene la
oportunidad de escribir discursos para
políticos y todo eso y mientras también
forme mi propia familia
en este entonces esta niña no sabía lo
que estaba empezando tampoco sabía que
en los 80s no iba a poder nunca tener el
pelo de cyndi lauper no sabía nada no
sabía nada no sabía las crisis que se
avecina bah no sabía nada pero lo que sí
sabía era que le gustaba estar conectada
con el mundo
ahora yo le diría pero viviste viviste
de mientras te dijeron el futuro es de
los jóvenes y te lo creíste también es
otra parte que nos cuenta la historia de
mientras y el futuro y el futuro pero un
día
anunciaron que se iba a acabar el mundo
si no ustedes no se acuerda pero se iba
a acabar el mundo se va a acabar el
mundo una bola de ceros y unos para
alguien como yo ven con mi mente está
más artística era inconcebible que unos
ceros de unos 1 si se fueran a acabar el
mundo no me lo creí en realidad pero
luego hay llamados hay ciertos llamados
todos tenemos algo dentro de nosotros
algo un murmullo no que se queda ahí y
con el ruido que nos arroja la vida
quizás no lo escuchamos ya veces
necesitamos que nos digan se te va a
acabar el mundo social se te va a acabar
el mundo y tú que has hecho
ellos pues sí hecho tengo mi familia he
hecho discursos he hecho muchas cosas
pero todo era por encargo todo era por
encargo y decir no has hecho muchas
cosas si estás muy contenta sí pero qué
has hecho de lo tuyo de lo tuyo es
verdaderamente tuyo de lo que te hacía
muy feliz
lo que me hacía feliz era escribir los
cuentos los cuentos que nunca la vida me
dijo eso puede ser tu vida nunca ningún
maestro ningún papá ninguna amiga nadie
nadie nunca me dijo
es que no te equivoques eso es lo tuyo
nunca nunca y eso es lo que me hacía más
feliz pero lo tuve que dejar de lado
porque me creí la otra historia y me
creí la historia de que el futuro es
tuyo y resulta que
en el año 2000 yo ya tenía 35 años se
tuvo que me tuvieron que amenazar que se
acaba el mundo para yo decir que es lo
tuyo lo tuyo son los cuentos bueno
quiero volver a escribir cuentos y fui a
un taller de creación literaria que en
el monterrey de los ochentas hubiera
sido inconcebible y resulta que la
primera pregunta que me hacen es que me
dicen de qué se trata tu novela
y yo
novela yo puedo soñar ese siempre había
sido mi sueño solo que si nos creemos
tanto la historia que nos cuentan nunca
nos atrevemos ni siquiera a denunciarlo
ni siquiera a creer que se puede hacer
nuestro sueño y en este con esa pregunta
porque luego a veces también este nos
cambió la vida cuando nos anuncian que
se acaba el mundo oa veces puede venir
con una sola pregunta con esa pregunta
si se acabó el mundo como yo lo conocía
y me fui a escribir mi primera novela la
siguiente semana ya trae el avance de mi
primera novela porque realmente dije ese
siempre había sido un sueño y lo bonito
de los sueños es que siempre decimos si
ese es el sueño y vamos tras él
y si lo dejamos el sueño crece y si lo
dejamos el sueño siempre está un poquito
más allá y vamos llegando a metas pero
el sueño siempre está un poquito más
allá y es lo que me ha pasado a mí y
resulta que esta fue mi primera novela
noche huracán se publicó aquí la
describí entre el año 2000 del año 2003
espere siete años a que fuera publicada
siete años sin saber qué hacer con ella
porque la mandé a mexico y sigo
esperando respuesta no se obtienen las
cosas tampoco tan fáciles pero yo no
sabía cómo hacer para que alguien me
escuchará no supe esa novela se guardó
siete años en un cajón y luego se
publicó en el año 2010
aquí una publicación muy pequeñita muy
pequeñita pero mi primer golpe de suerte
porque fíjate soy comunicóloga y creo en
el mensaje yo soy la emisora de una
novela
la novela es el mensaje pero nadie lo
había recibido nunca y resulta que esta
novela me abrió a la posibilidad de
ahora sí decir después de escribir una
novela soy novelista no hace nada más
que novelista porque cuando el receptor
recibió un mensaje y con entusiasmo dije
sí de esto se trata esto es lo que me
hace tan feliz y entonces en el 2010
cuando se publicó noche huracán me senté
a escribir
me queda poquito tiempo me senté a
escribir este me senté a escribir mi
segunda novela el mundo de las abejas
con mucha fe y con mucho entusiasmo la
escribí me tardé tres años luego bueno
se tardó otros dos años en el 2015 sale
el murmullo de las abejas
ahora sí tuve suerte otro golpe de
suerte en la ciudad de mexico en las
grandes editoriales alguien la leyó a
alguien le gustó y me dicen no digas qué
suerte sofía si a veces a veces también
tenemos que aferrarnos a la suerte
porque si no hubiera tenido suerte y
hubiera sucedido lo mismo que con la
otra novela una buena novela que no es
recibida y que no te abre no te abre
las puertas a la vida entera y para mí
eso fue el murmullo de las abejas
después del murmullo de las abejas si yo
huracán
su segunda oportunidad a nivel
internacional y bueno ahora estoy con
peregrinos la cosa que lo que yo les
quiero decir es que
por fin me llegó mi futuro pero mi
futuro es mi presente y esto es algo
bien filosófico y espero poder ser los
transmitir muy bien
les dicen que el futuro es de los
jóvenes pues sí sí es cierto es cierto
pero cuando es el futuro ahorita ya es
este es el futuro de hace rato cuando se
el futuro nos espera en mi generación
éramos más pacientes y nos decían el
futuro el futuro pues sí pero si les
seguimos así un día vamos a hacer unos
viejitos sentados en la mecedora y nos
van a llegar los nietos si no deben a
decir que estás haciendo abuelito los
esperando el futuro
verdad y no déjenme decirles unas cosas
el futuro es de todos es de todos porque
no sabemos en qué edad nos vamos a
encontrar lo verdaderamente nuestro en
qué edad vamos a dar con con esa eureka
ese momento de luz que yo ya tuve porque
mi murmullo este que yo tenía dentro me
decía tienes que ser escritora tienes
que ser novelista eso es lo tuyo ahora
yo los invito a pensar cuál es que que
les que murmuró tienen dentro del cuerpo
qué murmullo a este ya tienen desde los
15 años 16 17 ya está ya está yo no sé
qué van a estudiar lo que sea pero algo
tenemos muy único dentro de nosotros que
si de vez en cuando nos detuviéramos a
pagar todo el ruido que hay y los
videojuegos y los la música ahorita hay
tanta oportunidad de no hacernos caso de
no escucharnos por dentro
escuchen si de vez en cuando paguen
apaguen y de vez en cuando les distingan
que en una pregunta puede venir el
futuro el futuro es de todos porque no
importa si a los 50 a los 60 de repente
tenemos ese silencio o esa pregunta
especie especial que es nada más para
nosotros y entonces esa persona dice el
futuro es mío también
los presentes hacen el futuro el futuro
está hecho de presentes entonces así
como yo ahora le agradezco a esa niña
que fui que parecía que iba al baile
como cenicienta este no que tuviera por
lo menos esa colección quizás no tenía
mucha idea pero tenía una conexión y
leía y leía entonces si agarren su
futuro pero entienden que su futuro es
hoy y desde hoy ustedes pueden cambiar
este el mundo su mundo como déjenme
decirles que yo en carrera
todos mis cuentos nos tiren los del
colegio americano los de carrera los
tienen porque porque se acaba del año y
el cuaderno se iba porque era basura
porque nadie me decía este un día te va
a servir en carrera escribí un cuento
que se fue a la basura en algún momento
y resulta que cuando yo escribió el
mundo de las abejas me acordaba tanto de
ese cuento porque me ha dado tanto tanto
placer haberlo escrito tenía 21 años y
lo escribí en una fábula que me pidieron
y ese a partir de ese cuento se hace el
gran fundamento de un personaje que que
bueno ahora recorre el mundo entero pues
muy pronto en inglés también ha cruzado
todas las fronteras se llama simón obvio
ese cuento en referencia sin tenerlo en
mano se lo diga a él para que definiera
su mundo un cuento que yo escribí una
amiga me dijo ah tú lo tiraste pero yo
sí lo tengo yo lo guardé y entonces ya
ha publicado el murmullo de las abejas
ya para su edición de bolsillo
le dije a la editorial oye tengo este
cuento lo escribí cuando tenía 21 años y
me dijeron
danos no lo vamos a publicar junto con
el murmullo de las abejas en su segunda
edición
entonces déjenme decirles la juventud no
es de por mientras la juventud es la
gran oportunidad si se van a tardar
quizá tengan paciencia pero trabajen
todo el tiempo y distingan estén atentos
a su mundo atentos a su murmullo atentos
a su presente para que se hagan dueños
del futuro desde hoy porque él
future is now siempre es así es que
muchísimas gracias se me hace queda
parada
muchas gracias entonces
[Aplausos]